mari ecco il tuo regalo ma grazie do
degli orecchini di perle dal mio ultimo
viaggio di pim island mi sono immerso
nel mare ma sembrano di plastica che
plastica sono buttato con le bombole tra
gli enti subito degli squali capitale
non ci sono gli euro
c'è scritto no e si muore a città e con
sono fissati con gli adesivi queste per
te grazie una crema anti rughe e maria e
le prime rughe comunque i trenta sono le
porte ho pensato meglio prevenire che
curare no comunque è un altro vediamo
una crema anticellulite mariti o vista
l'altro giorno in palestra che ti cambia
vie ci hai dei buchi così mi sembra un
bel regalo bellissimo mari o qualcosa
per te ma è vuoto e no ma tutto insieme
no ecco qui grazie ma c'era uguale è si
aspetta la vado a prendere
vedi sono identiche mari questa qua e
nero petrolio che blu notte tipo
a me sembrano uguali vabbè comunque ti
piaceva tanto non li usate tanto ai la
scorta spero che di ghiaccio
grazie a questo quello che ho regalato
al tuo ragazzo l'anno scorso no no si è
anche la stessa taglia stessa marca ma
sai perché ora ti spiego oriente a lui
piaciuto tantissimo quindi ho detto sì
che lo compro ma ne do poi usciamo tutti
insieme avete maglioncino uguale troppo
carino no così ci organizziamo
ecco i mari il tuo regalo grazie e oro
18 carati
se passa ma gradi il tour e tano ok il
tuo regalo
l'ho preso io ho lasciato in macchina
però la macchina non è qui perché non
sono venuta in macchina la macchina da
mia nonna e mia nonna vita pavia quindi
appena vado a trovare nonna di porto
regalo va bene ma ti ricordi che vito
parigi certo imbatti verrò a trovarti a
parigi
non so dormire da te va bene casa nuova
regali importanti ma grazie donandovi
[Musica]
bicchieri di vetro di murano invece
avevano da dieci anni in casa si
tramandavano generazione in generazione
distrutte in un attimo ma come fai a
sopravvivere nel mondo sorpresa mari
grazie ciao
ma cos'è allora ti spiego questo qua e
il dietro
e poi ok ma finirà gamba no magari lo
vedo da sbrigare com
scusami e allora non importa cristiano
questa si mette dietro qua non è il caso
il fianco a casa loro dove si infilo
veramente ma questa linea della zanzare
tanto no non lo potrò mai mettere cioè
quando potrò mai ma a capodanno
ed è questo il nostro regalo idra ha
indovinato cos'è e cosa sarà mai un
libro profumo non è quella dai capi
domanda ora di capirlo lo sardo
buon natale amore quando lo vedi un
regalo davvero speciale
ma non solo un po cresciuto per i
peluche ma voleva non capisci leggi tra
le righe baby boy hey baby poi non ho
soprannome il solito mi chiamavi pulcino
però ma non capisci l'oggetto i colori
non lo so non ti realmente niente
azzurro e napoli dubito e sono del mio
amore
la famiglia che si allarga 2 che
diventano ringraziamo per le feste amore
ma non lo capisci sono incinta
aspettiamo un bambino
ok forse non l'ha presa benissimo ma se
non avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi subito al canale eseguite
visto tutti gli altri soci facebook
instagram è chi io vi mando un bacio e
lo spirito non l'ho scritto lo
striscione ciao
[Musica]